набагато важливіше це традиція яка є за
використовування
тому якщо ми справді хочемо цього
перейменування то очевидно нам в першу
чергу варто поступово запроваджувати цю
традицію використовувати в назву
Московія е-е до Росії здебільшого власне
законодавчі акти легалізують традицію
навпаки за керівники Московського
царства перед тим князівства використала
назву Росія - це
грецький варіант слова Русь власне для
того щоб присвоїти собі всю Монополію на
руську спадщину очевидно що нам треба
відвойовувати руську спадщину
перейменувати Росію в московію чи в
московшину ще один цікавий предмет для
дискусії Ми не можемо ухвалювати якісь
рішення які будуть виходити поза поза
межі України буду робитися на рівні
комісії з питань геодезії і кадастру що
теж трошки знаєте принижує значимість
цього питання але так принаймні поки що
передбачено по